step forward if you agree with the
prompt
boys are stronger than girls
well physically like for the most part
and gender roles and stuff like that
boys are just supposed to be strong or
that's just a thing that happens they
work out at the gym
and yeah girls certainly can work out
too if they want
but again it's more common for boys you
could be referring to strength in so
many ways like physically emotionally
where the strength in your body is
placed like it all just depends why do
they sound like high schoolers or like
kids like starting college they sound
exact same because they are
but they're middle schools like 12 11.
that's what's weird to me
there's not much difference
at my age i felt like all the kids were
[__]
yes you know what i'm saying
yes
like we didn't talk like this physically
emotionally what does that even [__]
mean this is vocabulary i said you have
to talk whenever you were a kid ted
talks to me yeah did you watch that talk
when you were a kid
youtube wasn't even around my point
exactly
you think
these kids probably are watching
everything
my point exactly i play volleyball and
sometimes we play the boys teams and we
like you know we've crushed them a
couple times and it feels so good you
know so i wouldn't necessarily i don't
agree with that yeah but you haven't hit
puberty yet that's when the game changer
happens once the hormones kick in and
dudes get that boost in testosterone
it's like it's like trying to compete
against a team with steroids you're just
not going to win you know
but they sound way older than they are
don't they don't sound older
they sound like it's just that they have
the confidence of
not knowing that it could actually be
wrong
uh let me ask you do you think 19 year
olds know that they could be wrong no
they sound older for that reason fair
you get what i'm saying people sound
like they if i if i never showed you
these people's age you just heard them
speak you would think they're in high
school sure
they have the they have the vocabulary
vocabulary is the same right and they
have the confidence then you have to add
the knowledge and the facts of life and
just you being in life and just living a
bit you understand what i'm saying
that's why those people that are very
extremists and want all these changes to
be done but don't actually do sports
they haven't really changed from them
you know i mean they're not so much
different from people they're not so
much different from people that haven't
hurt haven't hit puberty or haven't
really fought with guys you know i mean
or train with them that that's that's
kids who go through strenuous
experiences difficult hardships at a
young age are forced to grow older
exactly my point would you say would you
also think that kids who are exposed to
a lot more information a lot more
knowledge a lot more content at an early
age are maybe a little bit more worldly
or not necessarily knowledgeable
but maybe they just have more access to
information
not necessarily because information is
very vast
it's it's very vast right but
experiences
hits you in the face you get the
experiences and not i'm not saying that
those people that get the experiences
might not have their their reality a bit
[__] up because experiences doesn't uh
represent what the reality is but people
that had rough experiences have to grow
faster in a survival mode people that
have information still didn't have the
experience that's why you have the
difference between experience and
actually being on the ground there's a
science i don't disagree
yeah i don't know i'm just talking about
something i'm just saying we're talking
about some separate what i'm trying to
say is kids who go through difficult
things grow older
younger they have to right yeah because
the world makes them yeah the same way
you and i didn't grow up with this
information age the way these kids did
no right but we have to go out there we
we have to go out there but not like not
all of us but a lot of us do okay yeah
but my try my point is
we didn't have access to that
information we had access to maybe
experiences yeah okay they have access
to the information does that make them
have more knowledge not i'm talking
about experiential knowledge but just
information knowledge you get what i'm
saying they're going to be exposed to
new terms new concepts at a much younger
age new vocabulary much younger than we
were yeah
so it's like
we grow older faster due to experience i
feel like these kids are growing older
due to concepts through the concept and
words but so it sounds like they're
older but then after that the lack of
experience sounds like it's just like
whenever you hire someone for a job he
could talk about all these technical
words because he's just fresh out of
college or fresh out of university and
he's got that degree but the old timer
that's been in the job
that's been yeah yeah you got the words
i don't give a [__] uh give me that
number two that's not a number two i
don't give a [__] that's what i need to
the job i agree with you i agree with
you i think my point is there's a
difference between the knowledge that's
applicable through experience to
whatever it is that you're dealing with
and then the knowledge that gives you
the concept to conceptualize the world
yeah definitely i couldn't imagine what
other countries were like i couldn't
imagine what other realities were like
because as a kid you just have your
experience and you go through life with
whatever you touched and whatever you
interact with they are learning about
the trans experience they're learning
about what's happening in ukraine i
didn't understand that none of us
understood that so i feel like there's a
different i wouldn't even say maturity i
just feel like there's a different part
of their brain that seems to be
developing compared to us just me going
to
cuba at such a young age
yeah me traveling experiences right it's
in the book it's in the books i could
have read i got to read a book but i i
felt and i saw and i spoke to the people
and i was with the people so i see how
it felt like to be a cuban in those days
when i'm talking to my fellow americans
that did not have that experience
because they were not allowed
it was different and i could expect and
there were some things that i was
telling them that they could not
comprehend because they didn't they
didn't have that right especially a lot
of people from uh that were like that
are left
leaning and not leaning they're they're
they're left lying down all right
they're not leaning on it they're
straight on extremists they're really
leaning to communism and stuff like that
and different things but i'm like oh boo
boo boo boo girl
you're talking about that because you
lived in new york your whole [__]
life right right and to you that's this
and that and everything and stuff and
you're out of control you're the
exception though yes
in the sense that even during our age it
wasn't that common for kids to travel
nearly as much that's what i'm saying so
what i'm trying to say is like if i'm
just talking about generation to
generation yes your experience as a
generation is very different because the
fact that you had access to travis most
kids are kind of like me but we never
really got to go anywhere yeah so we
didn't experience communism firsthand to
have an understanding of it right
absolutely right so
they all are on technology yes but all
of them are learning about it
superfluously yeah but if you know we
didn't learn about it firsthand like i
understand what you're saying but like
let's see me going there and experiences
firsthand facts
them having the knowledge see if we talk
about knowledge knowledge to me
people view it as very positive right
right i view it that's very neutral
because knowledge can be positive
it can be negative i can give you
knowledge it's haronis knowledge it's
not real but it's knowledge no no no
it's fake knowledge it's not it's not
real thing it's knowledge you know about
that thing yeah you know about that
stuff yeah right they you you know you
think you feel knowledgeable and stuff
like that a lot of people have been
reading and doing history of of
of the world in america and stuff like
that and they were lied to because the
knowledge was
you have the knowledge you know the base
and everything and stuff but that
knowledge is really not real it's it's
it's agree i disagree because you're
having
a first-person bias to anything fair
right when you go there you have your
experience based off what you went
through being there right but that
doesn't mean that you actually have the
perspective to actually see what the
whole thing is like it's the same way
people were like well i lived in canada
and i didn't see any racism so it didn't
happen uh [__] that's your experience
that doesn't mean you have knowledge of
the experience you have your experience
yeah but everything is that it's and
that's where you have to make your the
difference yes between all of that it's
like you have to be smart enough and
that's where
who gives a [__] about knowledge if
you're not smart enough to comprehend
this and that i understand that i've
been there and i got the knowledge and
experience but i also have the smarts to
understand the different points of view
and that's what you have to understand
when it's the same thing when we went to
whenever we went when we sorry when we
went to haiti when we went to haiti we
saw things firsthand but we do
understand how they're positioning it
how they're you have to have the smarts
for that so knowledge is one thing right
but it's really just one part of the
equation yeah if if you don't have
everything in the equation you just have
random numbers you have to have the
whole thing and the whole and the so you
have to have knowledge and the smarts to
have it and i feel these kids they
really just have yeah knowledge
knowledge but she didn't acquire enough
smarts and critical thinking to put all
them pieces together and there's not
even like critique it's not even
[__] on them she's like it's a
different experience i was exactly that
i'm not [__] if i [__] on them and
[__] on myself these kids are so great
they don't even be [__] huh these
kids like when they get into teenage
years they don't [__] not as much as
the statistics show that kids are like
younger people are having way less sex
than our generations yeah they're like
out here reading about [__] and
watching you fear we actually was in
there you get what i'm saying it's a
different thing because you watching
four you get the impression everybody's
[__] the reality is most of these
kids don't get any nope yeah our
generation was way more [__]
debaucherous than these kids yeah they
were which is which is a weird thing to
imagine because you would not think that
based on how they talk about stuff and
how grown they sound they try to sound
but i also find like
their experience seems to be online more
than it is in person yeah so their
ability to interact with the opposite
sex or even with the same gender is like
way more awkward our experience was more
in on tv it was more like [__] throw
them in the fire and throw it and see it
see how they handle the
frying pan yeah
but
that's what i'm just taking away from
this video is just like how different
they are as kids than when we were kids
leave a like in a comment if you guys
are really blown away by this whole
conversation or it's like hitting you
guys as well you know let's talk about
youth were you guys like this when
you're younger no you're young people do
you think this shit's normal let us know
what you guys think i wanna i wanna hear
from y'all i think getting rid of like
these preconceived notions that like
boys go to gyms
what kind of 11 year old use the words
preconceived notions
but you know they've been on tick tock
and youtube and they've hurt everyone
else so they just absorbed yeah they
absorbed that stuff but imagine
i sounded smarter than my age just
because i ain't i was hanging around
those adults or older people or my
sister and her friends in them but the
older people that they hang out with is
tick tock and all that yeah i did you
ever been on tick tock it's like the
it's like the video version of twitter
it's another cesspool
but they also have dance videos
i am old enough to date
i'm shocked that they didn't all come
forward
i would assume that all these kids no
but it was comes back to that [__]
thing that i said earlier was like that
perception is there but the reality
seems to be different
obviously more of like figuring yourself
out comes in later years but i feel like
these relationships really shape how you
feel about relationships i can't i can't
take this seriously bro
how is this man sitting like you run the
law firm yeah what is going on it's just
they see what they they mimic but we yo
we were like that who was like that we
mimic what we see it's just that they
have access to much more but we mimic
what we see we mimic what we see bro but
we didn't see a lot we were middle
schoolers but we didn't see a lot uh we
saw enough did we oh yes what did you
see in middle school because i came in
after you and i didn't feel like anybody
was really acting old oh my god i mean
when i say they acted the age they acted
god not us it's crazy listen i went
through the phase of oh listen aaliyah
was up in there so all the girls had
that you know the tommy hilfiger boxing
show sponsors show is that showing and
then they put their pants down you know
what i mean put the black black black
lipstick on you know what i mean they
have the round the lip the the the black
surround and then the red lips or red
dark like cherry dark red you know i
mean that's what they used to do just
taking pauses and stuff like that girls
talking with their hands like that shut
up you're for a long game you're not
from new york sit your ass down but
that's what they used to see whenever
they used to go see their cuts same as
me whenever i used to go see my cousin i
see them acting like that
i agree we used to rock dicky pants and
[__] like long tease like we saw in
the rap videos i agree my thing is
at least they sounded young
once they started opening their mouths
like you shut up you 12 stupid these
kids got sitting out here like well you
know the preconceived notions of the
chakras and the way they intertwine
we had we had people like that but they
were dorks but we had the second you
guys had us yeah the whole section of
people that were like
staying in the library and stuff like
that they were like the corporate
[__] of the school they heard
the corporate hey what peep game peep
game so you had all the people libraries
glasses you know the ones that were in
the debates and stuff like that you know
all these [__] they were kind
of the corporate [__] speaking
like they were in the law firm well
actually sir blah blah blah yo
shut up and we were like the hood you
know what i mean [__] were
going [__] were going in during
the lunch time and smoke blends in the
park
so it was different fact it was really
that it was really that but they were
mimicking
older
younger version of whatever the [__]
they saw in the hood
and
it's important to have them yeah and i
mean i think that it begins to become
different when you get into like
the sexual aspects of a relationship and
dating
i think that this age
you don't know about enough about
yourself as a person at this age to give
consent
you know what's funny is a lot of people
are talking about like i'm not going my
kids access to tick-tock and social
media and all this stuff it don't even
matter if you do or not no because your
kids go to school and they're with kids
who watch tic-tac-toe they gonna watch
on their phone they go listen to
vocabulary they're going to get the same
concepts yeah it's over i hear these
kids speak you said it was the dork
square the library this is every kid now
yeah all the kids are the dorks that you
went to your school yeah it's a
different world i'm listening to them
speak and i'm like shocked yeah because
i watched jubilee the high school
version and these kids sound older than
them
i watched the college young college
students these kids sound as old as them
that's mad
that's mad that's different
it's just hitting me right now because i
i'll be around kids
obviously i'm not weird my tea i teach
in schools and i teach i i
i do uh lectures and [__] like that in
school and
they're different they different they
diff different yeah
we're not even gonna watch the whole
video probably watch another two three
minutes this is a powerful moment and
i think that like at age 12 it can be
kind of hard
to grasp that so you don't agree
you guys can date i'm me you're not me
so i personally would never date but you
guys do your thing it's like it's your
jazz not mine she's giving me preach
energy i'm not gonna lie
[Laughter]
she's
so i think there's just a lot more to
life before you have to slow down like i
want to ride my bike in the middle of
the street and then
binge eat popsicles and watch my
favorite tv show you like
middle of the street you're going to get
hit by a car
that's not smart to stay your ass on the
sidewalk [__] you don't want to be in
the middle of the middle of the middle
before i have to slow down which i have
seven more years before i'm officially
an adult so i think i won't no no you
don't you sound twenty
no no you sound like a no it's crazy how
these kids sound
uh i actually have a seven more years
before i'm officially an adult so i want
to just enjoy these like young youthful
years of my life as i get to ride my
bike beautifully through my street all
safely and deeply who talks like that
her
that's crazy these kids sound like so
eloquent it's like i was half [__]
jewel hanging out my mouth me like oh i
got baseball cards with pokemon cards
you want to trade my charizard for your
pikachu which is a bad trade but it
doesn't matter that's crazy see what
happened whenever you do like
with your [__] kids yeah talk to them
like adults and they're going to talk
like adults i don't know if i want my
kids to talk like that but they're going
to now hey i am mad at that yeah that is
a different car
this this little girl being a little bit
she is i think it's beautiful it's
beautiful this [__] is beautiful and
shout out to her parents too [__] doing
a wonderful job i think when we talk
about dating it's like we're going
through so much physiological change our
mental state is just so fragile and like
insane at this age that like
dating to me like the risk just
outweighs the reward and like
it's a risk
he's a he's a whole lawyer that's what
the [__] he is let's go shout out to you
kobe live your life live your life being
able
being able to express yourself like that
i think this [__] is wonderful live your
[__] life yeah
if you if you can put words like that
instead of saying [__] this [__] [__]
up no you're gonna be like no you know
our mental state is a bit fragile and
you know we can't really hey live your
[__] life
maybe 16's the new 18 maybe i'm just
loose i love i i i know for a fact
there's a bunch of pedals at home be
like no 10 is in your 18 mil
it's like the watching this [__] is
[__] weird bro well watching this
[__] for them is turning in the
off it's like oh
i thought i liked pre-progressing
highlight oh anyways we're gonna stop
there yeah yeah
it's not even a pause thing you can't
pause pat [__]
you can't pause pedal [__] stop yeah
yeah
stop stop didn't stop
take the tape recorder out stop burn the
[__]
[Laughter]
one dip is definitely going to be
applicable and everyone's like yeah yeah
yeah bundle you know what if jamaicans
were talking about metals all the time
i'm pretty sure everybody would have
been accepting it yeah yeah yeah yeah i
am not afraid shots are pedophiles
i am not afraid tell him if he stopped
the war
it would have been
it would have been lit i think i can
hold out like a few more years like i
don't think i need to like rush anything
and then i think at this age we're more
prone to you know like getting upset
over a smaller thing than what we would
be when we're older no no no no no no
no no wait no aren't these 12 years more
self-aware than [__] young adults
yeah
adults
scrap the young
adults put adults in there yes
yes
yes they are
that means that you know all this [__]
that we [__] up with this generation
there may be there may be there's hope
there's hope that's all i'm thinking
there's hope
it's good
at least you're asking the questions
girlfriend that's crazy bro that's
amazing that's i don't need to watch it
anymore this i can't no
culture maybe we'll finish another if
you guys really want to finish this
video let us know in the comments below
we won't that's what i wanted i wasn't
expecting this that's what you want to
aspire to that's exactly it
shut up just talk to your kids like
that's crazy people that's amazing
i'm all for it yeah i think childhood
just looks different today than it was
let kids be kids what does that even
mean anymore i don't know i have no idea
what that means anymore i think they're
so kids they just recognize their kids
the girl was like hey i want to ride my
bicycle the words are coming out of her
mouth doesn't
that doesn't remove the fact that hey i
want to do that i'll do that later i
don't want to date i'm going to do this
[__] right here let me ask you something
every young adult the first time they
pay their taxes what do they say
afterwards [__] i wish i wish i went
back i want to go ride my bike i want to
go ride my bike so do they really sound
that different than young adults no they
don't but they're self-aware
they're better away
they know they don't want to pay taxes
right now they know they want to ride
their bike the young adults need to pay
their taxes first oh [__] this is that's
how much i thought i was paid fifteen
dollars an hour how much oh this is why
you don't ever win
on your first on your first paycheck
have you ever go to you ever went to hr
and be like you're stealing money right
here no this is the taxes this is this
is the government this is that and
that's what you're left with on every
paycheck yes have a good day rough i'm
blown away i'm legitimately they
actually know but hey you know
yeah this is really shocking for me but
let us know what you guys think in the
comments man that's amazing
i love the progress